first minutes that why shouldn't the UK
government set out all of the potential
problems of leaving in bright technical
ass of the public know what the risks
are I mean the UK governmentís of course
perfectly in takes up to do that I'm not
questioning that I'm simply making the
point based on both my belief but also
my experience of having been involved in
a referendum quite recently is that
people respond to and engage much better
with positive argument so that why we
should do something as opposed to the
argument about why we shouldn't and and
I think this is an opportunity to set
out the positive in principle reasons
why for all its imperfections membership
of the EU a good thing for the UK and
certainly I think it's a good thing for
Scotland so it's up to the UK government
and David Cameron and how he wants to
campaign but I think it's important to
make a positive case and that's what
I've tried to do I mean you know
remember that we were the course of the
Scottish independence referendum that
the naut campaign you know started out
with a 20-point plus lead and saw that
diminish and diminish and diminish and
the result was in the end of the day
feeling that or now the end campaign
here doesn't have a 20-point lead to
squander so I think it's better to make
a positive case there are plenty good
reasons for staying in the EU let's have
that positive case and I think again
based on the experience of the Scottish
referendum when people are encouraged to
an able to see you know the positive
reasons for doing something and I think
that leads to a much healthier and much
better to be and I think in this case it
is more likely to lead to what I
consider to be the right outcome
I suppose in both cases though in both
the Scottish referendum and Eva
and the government's making a judgement
that these fears and these risks are
very real you you run the risk of
insulting people's intelligence because
you know already you can see things that
they said during the Scottish referendum
that they're now saying the opposite of
in this referendum you know I woke up
this morning to hear the UK government
see that if there was a vote to leave
the EU then it would take at least 10
years for the UK to manage to negotiate
its way out of the EU the Scottish
referendum they said the same people
said that it's Scotland voted to be
independent we'd be thrown out overnight
no empty phone what daft and we
shouldn't treat people as if the data
what are the scare mongering was
overblown in the Scottish referendum
when it would be overblown in this one -
I want to see the UK vote to stay and I
think that is more likely to happen if
we actually engage in the positive
benefits that the EU brings and the
positive reasons for staying and they're
supposed to trying to insult people's
intelligence with scare stories that
they probably know are not completely
true and will not be completely born it
is it an issue that the project fear
exists on both sides of the equation
absolutely never to see you know that
there's no doubt what's a diamond and
what outcome I want to see but I do
think that is an opportunity for both
sides to be positive you know say oh the
case
positively let people debate let people
make up their minds and well I hope
there's that I've ought to see in if
it's a positive to be about how people
see and envision the future then it
we're better to be and whatever the
outcome is it will leave a more positive
legacy so you know that would be a
message that I would get to both sides
of the campaign I'm only able to control
how my party campaigns and we will seek
to campaign positively and put forward
the reasons not just the economic
reasons but the social and employment
reasons for remaining within the EU what
you say it's a small proportion of your
supporters who are very excited about
England voting to leave and taking
Scotland out against its will because
that will be
the best chance of reprisals there's got
furniture well the scenario that's
talked about what happens if you know
the U keyboards the commode that
Scotland works to see and of course does
the pained of Scotland to stay in and
you know when I talk about that scenario
I'm simply setting out what I think
would be a natural consequence of that
happening but it's not what I want to
see I want starting to become
independent but I don't want Scotland to
become independent because the UK votes
to come out of the EU will be better in
the future for an independent Scotland
if England is also in the European Union
so I'm not trying to you know bring a
boat this scenario even if I was I
wouldn't be able to but I'm not trying
to I hope the England Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland vote to steered and
then I'll make the case for Scottish
independence and it's much wider made
it's the possibility I think in these
circumstances you couldn't exclude that
possibility and you know it would be
undemocratic to in the Scottish
referendum people were told that our EU
membership would be at risk if we voted
yes well Scotland voted no albeit
Natalie two then two years later find
that we were particular in the European
Union I think would lead a lot of people
I add this is anecdotal but I know
people who voted no proudly and
passionately in the Scottish referendum
who bid walk definitely if we were being
taken out of the EU but the point I'm
making here is that's not what I hope
happens so you know I will be
campaigning for an invert and I hope
that in vote is one in every nation of
the UK why are you so keen to remove
Scotland from the yoke of Westminster
that's just a ridiculous way of putting
it you know every single member state of
the European Union is an independent
country many of them have populations
smaller than Scotland's so the European
Union is made up of independent
countries I would like Scotland to be
one of those independent countries and
as an independent country to participate
in British Isles with the other nations
of the British Isles on that basis of
equality in the modern water would we
live
today there is no contradiction
whatsoever between independence and
interdependence that's the way of the
world but you have no fears it's all
about Brussels become a little bit I
don't think the European Union is
perfect you know I've over recent times
argued for things that I think should
change about the European Union you know
I give you one example I think there
should be much more discretion for
domestic governments over public health
measures and I say that as the first
minister of a government that his has
had a lot of difficulty trying to
introduce a minimum price for alcohol
because of European law so there are
many things I would choose to change
about the European Union but I think
we're better off in the arguing for that
change from within rather than coming
out there's a clear progressive case
against the EU it's talking about the
TTIP trade deal you know you obviously
are unaware of this there's progressives
worried about Brussels being too
powerful and telling the likes of Greece
and Spain and Ireland I recognize all of
those concerns but I still think it's
better given the the bottom you take
employment and social protections right
now I mean some of the standards we have
in the UK are probably only because of
you directors if you take maternity and
paternal leave parental leave if you
take some you know holiday entitlements
do we really think that a Tory UK
government would hunt up all of these
protections if they were obliged to by
the European Union so there's a strong
progressive case and it's a case I will
meet for staying in it doesn't mean
turning a blind eye to the imperfections
of Europe if you take TTIP for example
yeah the UK government should be doing
more to insist that the NHS is exempted
from TTIP that public services generally
are exempted that we shouldn't have the
ability of companies to sue States
that's a it may be a feeling of the UK
government in nor insisting on these
things rather than an inevitable feeling
of the European Union to what degree
coordinating we've got
you're campaigning in Scotland and
perhaps you're seeing some of the
initiatives put by the government under
which opposition parties are suffering
whether it's the cuts to the amount of
money Parliament you get in Parliament
the short money or whether the trade
union bill affecting funding of other
opposition parties whether you think the
government's just layoffs there were
certain parties if they want you to
campaign thoroughly I think he was job
I think they should lay off these things
regardless of the European Union
referendum I oppose what the government
is trying to do to Road trade union
rights I oppose what they're trying to
do for petty partisan reasons around or
position party funding but that's not
associate anything you write for it in
them I think these things are wrong and
actually they do make a point here in
terms of the EU referendum that's like
in a behavior of the Tory in government
when it's unfettered by Europe so let's
keep the involvement of the European
Union in terms of these employment and
social protections rather than have
David Cameron and his government have a
free-for-all